This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We typically divide the United States into two political categories. Conservative, and Liberal. Frankly, I don't care what the Republicans say. Finding common ground between these two groups. Who is on this and who is on your... Reaching across the aisle. After a far-latched radical base has become increasingly rare.
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We typically divide the United States into two political categories. Conservative, and Liberal. Frankly, I don't care what the Republicans say. Finding common ground between these two groups. Who is on this and who is on your... Reaching across the aisle. After a far-latched radical base has become increasingly rare.|||This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We typically divide the United States into two political categories. Conservative, and Liberal. Frankly, I don't care what the Republicans say. Finding common ground between these two groups. Who is on this and who is on your... Reaching across the aisle. After a far-latched radical base has become increasingly rare.
Because we keep trying to find a way to win without help from across the aisle. This is true not just in a metaphorical sense. In one study, researchers looked at more than 1400 hours of tape. Now, I've sent it coverage on C-SPAN. On C-SPAN 2. The Senate will come to order the chat. Hour after hour of hearings. Some common roads and bridges and air-puppets., committee markup sessions, congresses a very important pillar.
Because we keep trying to find a way to win without help from across the aisle. This is true not just in a metaphorical sense. In one study, researchers looked at more than 1400 hours of tape. Now, I've sent it coverage on C-SPAN. On C-SPAN 2. The Senate will come to order the chat. Hour after hour of hearings. Some common roads and bridges and air-puppets., committee markup sessions, congresses a very important pillar.|||Because we keep trying to find a way to win without help from across the aisle. This is true not just in a metaphorical sense. In one study, researchers looked at more than 1400 hours of tape. Now, I've sent it coverage on C-SPAN. On C-SPAN 2. The Senate will come to order the chat. Hour after hour of hearings. Some common roads and bridges and air-puppets., committee markup sessions, congresses a very important pillar.
Testimony, resolution, the clerk will call the roll. After all these hours watching C-SPAN, researchers concluded that since the 1990s, Democrats and Republicans in the U.S. Senate have physically crossed the aisle less and less to interact with opposing colleagues. That means Senators are staying with their like-minded colleagues, not just in the legislation they are trying to pass, but also by literally steering clear of the carpeted pathway that splits the Senate floor in half. In other words, just like the rest of the nation, the Senate is more divided than ever,
Testimony, resolution, the clerk will call the roll. After all these hours watching C-SPAN, researchers concluded that since the 1990s, Democrats and Republicans in the U.S. Senate have physically crossed the aisle less and less to interact with opposing colleagues. That means Senators are staying with their like-minded colleagues, not just in the legislation they are trying to pass, but also by literally steering clear of the carpeted pathway that splits the Senate floor in half. In other words, just like the rest of the nation, the Senate is more divided than ever,|||Testimony, resolution, the clerk will call the roll. After all these hours watching C-SPAN, researchers concluded that since the 1990s, Democrats and Republicans in the U.S. Senate have physically crossed the aisle less and less to interact with opposing colleagues. That means Senators are staying with their like-minded colleagues, not just in the legislation they are trying to pass, but also by literally steering clear of the carpeted pathway that splits the Senate floor in half. In other words, just like the rest of the nation, the Senate is more divided than ever,
and this divide can leave us feeling helpless and hopeless. Today though, we're going to take a few steps back. We're going to look at the challenge of political division through a new lens. It's part of our October series exploring counterintuitive ideas in 2020. We hope it will provide a new way to understand the people sitting across from us at the dinner table. People don't seem to dislike somebody just for being a member of the other side. They're concerned that somebody is going to talk to them about politics, and if somebody's going to talk to you about politics, of course you'd rather talk to somebody
and this divide can leave us feeling helpless and hopeless. Today though, we're going to take a few steps back. We're going to look at the challenge of political division through a new lens. It's part of our October series exploring counterintuitive ideas in 2020. We hope it will provide a new way to understand the people sitting across from us at the dinner table. People don't seem to dislike somebody just for being a member of the other side. They're concerned that somebody is going to talk to them about politics, and if somebody's going to talk to you about politics, of course you'd rather talk to somebody|||and this divide can leave us feeling helpless and hopeless. Today though, we're going to take a few steps back. We're going to look at the challenge of political division through a new lens. It's part of our October series exploring counterintuitive ideas in 2020. We hope it will provide a new way to understand the people sitting across from us at the dinner table. People don't seem to dislike somebody just for being a member of the other side. They're concerned that somebody is going to talk to them about politics, and if somebody's going to talk to you about politics, of course you'd rather talk to somebody
of your own side. This week on Hidden Brain, why the division you hear about all the time in our politics might not be what really divides us. Yana Kripnikov is a political scientist at Stony Brook University. She studies a subject we hear a lot about, the bitter political divide in the United States. But Yana has a counterintuitive thesis. She thinks the real fault line in America
of your own side. This week on Hidden Brain, why the division you hear about all the time in our politics might not be what really divides us. Yana Kripnikov is a political scientist at Stony Brook University. She studies a subject we hear a lot about, the bitter political divide in the United States. But Yana has a counterintuitive thesis. She thinks the real fault line in America|||of your own side. This week on Hidden Brain, why the division you hear about all the time in our politics might not be what really divides us. Yana Kripnikov is a political scientist at Stony Brook University. She studies a subject we hear a lot about, the bitter political divide in the United States. But Yana has a counterintuitive thesis. She thinks the real fault line in America
is actually not between Republicans and Democrats. Yana Kriplinkov, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. I want to play your clip, Yana, from a CNN program titled, Welcome to the Fractured States of America. The number of parents who would be unhappy if their child married someone
is actually not between Republicans and Democrats. Yana Kriplinkov, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. I want to play your clip, Yana, from a CNN program titled, Welcome to the Fractured States of America. The number of parents who would be unhappy if their child married someone|||is actually not between Republicans and Democrats. Yana Kriplinkov, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. I want to play your clip, Yana, from a CNN program titled, Welcome to the Fractured States of America. The number of parents who would be unhappy if their child married someone
of a different political party, that number has exploded over the last several decades. From 4% in 1960 to 35% of Republicans and 45% of Democrats in 2018. So, Yana, you have a critique of this notion of a fractured country, but I want you to start by laying out the conventional wisdom first. What are we told about the state of political polarization
of a different political party, that number has exploded over the last several decades. From 4% in 1960 to 35% of Republicans and 45% of Democrats in 2018. So, Yana, you have a critique of this notion of a fractured country, but I want you to start by laying out the conventional wisdom first. What are we told about the state of political polarization|||of a different political party, that number has exploded over the last several decades. From 4% in 1960 to 35% of Republicans and 45% of Democrats in 2018. So, Yana, you have a critique of this notion of a fractured country, but I want you to start by laying out the conventional wisdom first. What are we told about the state of political polarization
in America? A lot of what we're told about the state of political polarization is that polarization has increased quite vastly over potentially the last decade. What's interesting about this polarization is that there's a twofold approach here. So on the one hand, polarization can be ideological, but on the other hand, it can be effective. An affective polarization is the sense of disliking somebody just because they're a member of the other party, without their issues, without kind of theiriking somebody just because they're a member of the other party without their issues,
in America? A lot of what we're told about the state of political polarization is that polarization has increased quite vastly over potentially the last decade. What's interesting about this polarization is that there's a twofold approach here. So on the one hand, polarization can be ideological, but on the other hand, it can be effective. An affective polarization is the sense of disliking somebody just because they're a member of the other party, without their issues, without kind of theiriking somebody just because they're a member of the other party without their issues,|||in America? A lot of what we're told about the state of political polarization is that polarization has increased quite vastly over potentially the last decade. What's interesting about this polarization is that there's a twofold approach here. So on the one hand, polarization can be ideological, but on the other hand, it can be effective. An affective polarization is the sense of disliking somebody just because they're a member of the other party, without their issues, without kind of theiriking somebody just because they're a member of the other party without their issues,
without kind of their positions, just because they belong to the opposing group. So when we talk about Democrats not wanting their child to marry a Republican or Republicans not wanting their child to marry a Democrat, we are talking often about this idea of affect. Does this sense of dislike this antipathy for the other side? And there's this tremendous kind of pattern showing increases in this level of antipathy, that people who are from one party just dislike the other party much more than they did in years past. And some of this is almost to an extreme. I mean, some people have even asked whether ordinary Americans see their political opponents as even fully human. Indeed, there's actually a lot of examples of this antipathy.
without kind of their positions, just because they belong to the opposing group. So when we talk about Democrats not wanting their child to marry a Republican or Republicans not wanting their child to marry a Democrat, we are talking often about this idea of affect. Does this sense of dislike this antipathy for the other side? And there's this tremendous kind of pattern showing increases in this level of antipathy, that people who are from one party just dislike the other party much more than they did in years past. And some of this is almost to an extreme. I mean, some people have even asked whether ordinary Americans see their political opponents as even fully human. Indeed, there's actually a lot of examples of this antipathy.|||without kind of their positions, just because they belong to the opposing group. So when we talk about Democrats not wanting their child to marry a Republican or Republicans not wanting their child to marry a Democrat, we are talking often about this idea of affect. Does this sense of dislike this antipathy for the other side? And there's this tremendous kind of pattern showing increases in this level of antipathy, that people who are from one party just dislike the other party much more than they did in years past. And some of this is almost to an extreme. I mean, some people have even asked whether ordinary Americans see their political opponents as even fully human. Indeed, there's actually a lot of examples of this antipathy.
There's research suggesting that people wouldn't want somebody to, as I just said, marry somebody from the other party, that they wouldn't want to hire somebody from the opposing party, that they don't see the other party as human, that they wouldn't want to hire somebody from the opposing party that they don't see the other party as human, that they might actually want to do something that would make life for somebody from the opposing party much worse. So there are a lot of these almost non-political examples of places where partisanship and dislike for the other side has quite profoundly affected the way we see the world and the way we see other people. So we're told Americans don't want to live next to one another, political partisans that is, they can't bear to talk to one another,
There's research suggesting that people wouldn't want somebody to, as I just said, marry somebody from the other party, that they wouldn't want to hire somebody from the opposing party, that they don't see the other party as human, that they wouldn't want to hire somebody from the opposing party that they don't see the other party as human, that they might actually want to do something that would make life for somebody from the opposing party much worse. So there are a lot of these almost non-political examples of places where partisanship and dislike for the other side has quite profoundly affected the way we see the world and the way we see other people. So we're told Americans don't want to live next to one another, political partisans that is, they can't bear to talk to one another,|||There's research suggesting that people wouldn't want somebody to, as I just said, marry somebody from the other party, that they wouldn't want to hire somebody from the opposing party, that they don't see the other party as human, that they wouldn't want to hire somebody from the opposing party that they don't see the other party as human, that they might actually want to do something that would make life for somebody from the opposing party much worse. So there are a lot of these almost non-political examples of places where partisanship and dislike for the other side has quite profoundly affected the way we see the world and the way we see other people. So we're told Americans don't want to live next to one another, political partisans that is, they can't bear to talk to one another,
and of course they don't want their children marrying people from the other party. You conducted a survey some years ago when you drill down specifically on the marriage question. What was the hunch you were exploring and what did you ask? So the way we looked at the marriage question happened during these conversations I had had with my co-authors, John Barry Ryan and Samarit Clark. And so we were talking about this marriage question that something about it seemed quite unusual to us.
and of course they don't want their children marrying people from the other party. You conducted a survey some years ago when you drill down specifically on the marriage question. What was the hunch you were exploring and what did you ask? So the way we looked at the marriage question happened during these conversations I had had with my co-authors, John Barry Ryan and Samarit Clark. And so we were talking about this marriage question that something about it seemed quite unusual to us.|||and of course they don't want their children marrying people from the other party. You conducted a survey some years ago when you drill down specifically on the marriage question. What was the hunch you were exploring and what did you ask? So the way we looked at the marriage question happened during these conversations I had had with my co-authors, John Barry Ryan and Samarit Clark. And so we were talking about this marriage question that something about it seemed quite unusual to us.
You are in a survey, you're being asked whether you want your child to marry somebody from the other party, but that's really all you know about this person. All you know about them is that they are a Republican or that they are a Democrat. And when that's all you know about them, one, you can't really put that person into context. But the other thing you might think about them is essentially, if they're telling me
You are in a survey, you're being asked whether you want your child to marry somebody from the other party, but that's really all you know about this person. All you know about them is that they are a Republican or that they are a Democrat. And when that's all you know about them, one, you can't really put that person into context. But the other thing you might think about them is essentially, if they're telling me|||You are in a survey, you're being asked whether you want your child to marry somebody from the other party, but that's really all you know about this person. All you know about them is that they are a Republican or that they are a Democrat. And when that's all you know about them, one, you can't really put that person into context. But the other thing you might think about them is essentially, if they're telling me
this person's partisanship, that person's partisanship is probably something that's really, really important to them. So if I was inviting you to meet one of my friends and we had just a brief moment, and I used that brief moment to tell you, you're gonna meet my friend, she likes cats. You might imagine that you're about to meet somebody who is essentially going to talk nonstop about cats. If that's the only thing I shared with you about this person. And so what if this is what's happening in a survey? What if when people are asked
this person's partisanship, that person's partisanship is probably something that's really, really important to them. So if I was inviting you to meet one of my friends and we had just a brief moment, and I used that brief moment to tell you, you're gonna meet my friend, she likes cats. You might imagine that you're about to meet somebody who is essentially going to talk nonstop about cats. If that's the only thing I shared with you about this person. And so what if this is what's happening in a survey? What if when people are asked|||this person's partisanship, that person's partisanship is probably something that's really, really important to them. So if I was inviting you to meet one of my friends and we had just a brief moment, and I used that brief moment to tell you, you're gonna meet my friend, she likes cats. You might imagine that you're about to meet somebody who is essentially going to talk nonstop about cats. If that's the only thing I shared with you about this person. And so what if this is what's happening in a survey? What if when people are asked
about this hypothetical in law and the only thing they know about this person is that they're a member of the opposing party. What if they're imagining somebody who will literally talk about politics for every dinner from now on as they're in-law? And what did you find when you actually asked Americans this question? How did you tweak the question and what did you find? So we ended up doing is we amended the question a bit. We basically added a qualification. We told people that this future in law, this hypothetical in law, was actually never really going to talk about politics. They might be from the other parties,
about this hypothetical in law and the only thing they know about this person is that they're a member of the opposing party. What if they're imagining somebody who will literally talk about politics for every dinner from now on as they're in-law? And what did you find when you actually asked Americans this question? How did you tweak the question and what did you find? So we ended up doing is we amended the question a bit. We basically added a qualification. We told people that this future in law, this hypothetical in law, was actually never really going to talk about politics. They might be from the other parties,|||about this hypothetical in law and the only thing they know about this person is that they're a member of the opposing party. What if they're imagining somebody who will literally talk about politics for every dinner from now on as they're in-law? And what did you find when you actually asked Americans this question? How did you tweak the question and what did you find? So we ended up doing is we amended the question a bit. We basically added a qualification. We told people that this future in law, this hypothetical in law, was actually never really going to talk about politics. They might be from the other parties,
but they were never actually going to discuss anything political. And so we ran an experiment in which people were randomly assigned to either a group in which they got asked the normal question, how happy would you be if your child married somebody from the opposing party? Versus a question in which they were told, how happy would you be if your child married somebody from an opposing party, but this person was never going to talk about politics. And what we found is significant differences in people's preferences for the other side. Once people were told that their child's future spouse was actually not really going to talk about politics, their animosity toward the other side quite profoundly decreased. In other words, if I was a Republican parent, the thing that I might be most worried about
but they were never actually going to discuss anything political. And so we ran an experiment in which people were randomly assigned to either a group in which they got asked the normal question, how happy would you be if your child married somebody from the opposing party? Versus a question in which they were told, how happy would you be if your child married somebody from an opposing party, but this person was never going to talk about politics. And what we found is significant differences in people's preferences for the other side. Once people were told that their child's future spouse was actually not really going to talk about politics, their animosity toward the other side quite profoundly decreased. In other words, if I was a Republican parent, the thing that I might be most worried about|||but they were never actually going to discuss anything political. And so we ran an experiment in which people were randomly assigned to either a group in which they got asked the normal question, how happy would you be if your child married somebody from the opposing party? Versus a question in which they were told, how happy would you be if your child married somebody from an opposing party, but this person was never going to talk about politics. And what we found is significant differences in people's preferences for the other side. Once people were told that their child's future spouse was actually not really going to talk about politics, their animosity toward the other side quite profoundly decreased. In other words, if I was a Republican parent, the thing that I might be most worried about
is not that my child is going to marry a Democrat, my child is going to marry a Democrat who is going to talk politics all the time. If I had the reassurance that politics was not going to come up all the time, my feelings about my future Democratic Sun and Law or doctrine law changed quite profoundly. Exactly. In theory, what people were concerned about is essentially politics coming up in their day-to-day lives. They actually were not as concerned about the opposing partisanship component of it. To better understand how this played out in people's lives, Yana and her colleagues ran the study again, but changed whether the hypothetical new daughter or son-in-law talked about politics frequently,
is not that my child is going to marry a Democrat, my child is going to marry a Democrat who is going to talk politics all the time. If I had the reassurance that politics was not going to come up all the time, my feelings about my future Democratic Sun and Law or doctrine law changed quite profoundly. Exactly. In theory, what people were concerned about is essentially politics coming up in their day-to-day lives. They actually were not as concerned about the opposing partisanship component of it. To better understand how this played out in people's lives, Yana and her colleagues ran the study again, but changed whether the hypothetical new daughter or son-in-law talked about politics frequently,|||is not that my child is going to marry a Democrat, my child is going to marry a Democrat who is going to talk politics all the time. If I had the reassurance that politics was not going to come up all the time, my feelings about my future Democratic Sun and Law or doctrine law changed quite profoundly. Exactly. In theory, what people were concerned about is essentially politics coming up in their day-to-day lives. They actually were not as concerned about the opposing partisanship component of it. To better understand how this played out in people's lives, Yana and her colleagues ran the study again, but changed whether the hypothetical new daughter or son-in-law talked about politics frequently,
occasionally, or rarely. They found that what people cared about the most was not whether a future son-in-law or daughter-in-law had different politics, but how much the future in law wanted to talk about politics. People don't seem to dislike somebody just for being a member of the other side. They're concerned that somebody is going to talk to them about politics, and if somebody is going to talk to you about politics, of course you'd rather talk to them about politics. And if somebody's going to talk to you about politics, of course, you'd rather talk to somebody of your own side. If that's going to be part of your life at every dinner,
occasionally, or rarely. They found that what people cared about the most was not whether a future son-in-law or daughter-in-law had different politics, but how much the future in law wanted to talk about politics. People don't seem to dislike somebody just for being a member of the other side. They're concerned that somebody is going to talk to them about politics, and if somebody is going to talk to you about politics, of course you'd rather talk to them about politics. And if somebody's going to talk to you about politics, of course, you'd rather talk to somebody of your own side. If that's going to be part of your life at every dinner,|||occasionally, or rarely. They found that what people cared about the most was not whether a future son-in-law or daughter-in-law had different politics, but how much the future in law wanted to talk about politics. People don't seem to dislike somebody just for being a member of the other side. They're concerned that somebody is going to talk to them about politics, and if somebody is going to talk to you about politics, of course you'd rather talk to them about politics. And if somebody's going to talk to you about politics, of course, you'd rather talk to somebody of your own side. If that's going to be part of your life at every dinner,
certainly, of course, you wouldn't want it to be contentious. But the key aspect there is conversations not necessarily partisanship. So I'm thinking of a clip from Saturday Night Live that I think your research speaks to. It's actually about a wedding celebration, and the celebration is interrupted by the character known as Debbie Downer. Yeah, these mashed potatoes look like heaven. After we, I vote we get a line dance.
certainly, of course, you wouldn't want it to be contentious. But the key aspect there is conversations not necessarily partisanship. So I'm thinking of a clip from Saturday Night Live that I think your research speaks to. It's actually about a wedding celebration, and the celebration is interrupted by the character known as Debbie Downer. Yeah, these mashed potatoes look like heaven. After we, I vote we get a line dance.|||certainly, of course, you wouldn't want it to be contentious. But the key aspect there is conversations not necessarily partisanship. So I'm thinking of a clip from Saturday Night Live that I think your research speaks to. It's actually about a wedding celebration, and the celebration is interrupted by the character known as Debbie Downer. Yeah, these mashed potatoes look like heaven. After we, I vote we get a line dance.
Oh yeah. Hey, speaking of voting, how do you guys feel about Trump? What do you think, Anna? Do you think that clip speaks to your thesis? I think it speaks to the thesis quite profoundly, but I think actually that is exactly what people are quite worried about. You're having kind of a nice celebration. Somebody comes in for whom politics is incredibly important, who is essentially going to change the conversation to that
Oh yeah. Hey, speaking of voting, how do you guys feel about Trump? What do you think, Anna? Do you think that clip speaks to your thesis? I think it speaks to the thesis quite profoundly, but I think actually that is exactly what people are quite worried about. You're having kind of a nice celebration. Somebody comes in for whom politics is incredibly important, who is essentially going to change the conversation to that|||Oh yeah. Hey, speaking of voting, how do you guys feel about Trump? What do you think, Anna? Do you think that clip speaks to your thesis? I think it speaks to the thesis quite profoundly, but I think actually that is exactly what people are quite worried about. You're having kind of a nice celebration. Somebody comes in for whom politics is incredibly important, who is essentially going to change the conversation to that
particular bend. So imagine that every dinner you're now incredibly tense, trying to figure out, is there something political that's going to happen here? I think that's what people are deeply concerned about. Imagine sitting at dinner with friends and family. Someone mentions a tweet from Trump. Everyone freezes. Will this become an argument? Yana's data suggests that if the people around your table were a cross-section of America, most would prefer to change the topic. But some people would get super excited. It's these people who would also be really upset if a child of theirs were to marry someone from the other party.
particular bend. So imagine that every dinner you're now incredibly tense, trying to figure out, is there something political that's going to happen here? I think that's what people are deeply concerned about. Imagine sitting at dinner with friends and family. Someone mentions a tweet from Trump. Everyone freezes. Will this become an argument? Yana's data suggests that if the people around your table were a cross-section of America, most would prefer to change the topic. But some people would get super excited. It's these people who would also be really upset if a child of theirs were to marry someone from the other party.|||particular bend. So imagine that every dinner you're now incredibly tense, trying to figure out, is there something political that's going to happen here? I think that's what people are deeply concerned about. Imagine sitting at dinner with friends and family. Someone mentions a tweet from Trump. Everyone freezes. Will this become an argument? Yana's data suggests that if the people around your table were a cross-section of America, most would prefer to change the topic. But some people would get super excited. It's these people who would also be really upset if a child of theirs were to marry someone from the other party.
There certainly is a group of people who are in fact effectively polarized. No matter how we describe this in law, they are displeased with their child marrying somebody of the opposing side. I would bet that even if we told them politics will literally never come up ever, ever, ever, they would still be displeased
There certainly is a group of people who are in fact effectively polarized. No matter how we describe this in law, they are displeased with their child marrying somebody of the opposing side. I would bet that even if we told them politics will literally never come up ever, ever, ever, they would still be displeased|||There certainly is a group of people who are in fact effectively polarized. No matter how we describe this in law, they are displeased with their child marrying somebody of the opposing side. I would bet that even if we told them politics will literally never come up ever, ever, ever, they would still be displeased
that their child married somebody of the opposing party. These people struck us as being what we would term unconditionally polarized. They were sort of polarized exactly in the sense of hating somebody just because they are from the other side. And as we dove into this question further, we wanted to investigate exactly what contributes to this unconditional polarization, what correlates with somebody disliking somebody just from being a member of the other side, which led us to this idea of certain people being deeply involved in politics. People for whom politics has become so profoundly important that it is something beyond just an interest in politics.
that their child married somebody of the opposing party. These people struck us as being what we would term unconditionally polarized. They were sort of polarized exactly in the sense of hating somebody just because they are from the other side. And as we dove into this question further, we wanted to investigate exactly what contributes to this unconditional polarization, what correlates with somebody disliking somebody just from being a member of the other side, which led us to this idea of certain people being deeply involved in politics. People for whom politics has become so profoundly important that it is something beyond just an interest in politics.|||that their child married somebody of the opposing party. These people struck us as being what we would term unconditionally polarized. They were sort of polarized exactly in the sense of hating somebody just because they are from the other side. And as we dove into this question further, we wanted to investigate exactly what contributes to this unconditional polarization, what correlates with somebody disliking somebody just from being a member of the other side, which led us to this idea of certain people being deeply involved in politics. People for whom politics has become so profoundly important that it is something beyond just an interest in politics.
So, as you say, the deeply involved care a lot about politics, like Debbie Downer, they want to talk about politics, even to people who want to talk about something else. But you make a remarkable claim. You say the central fault line today in the United States might not be between Republicans and Democrats, but between people who are deeply involved in politics and everybody else, what do you mean by that? When we think about deep involvement, we think of somebody for whom politics is front and center. It is something that they think about on a daily basis. It's something that they think about actually probably on an hourly basis. It is something that is a center to the way
So, as you say, the deeply involved care a lot about politics, like Debbie Downer, they want to talk about politics, even to people who want to talk about something else. But you make a remarkable claim. You say the central fault line today in the United States might not be between Republicans and Democrats, but between people who are deeply involved in politics and everybody else, what do you mean by that? When we think about deep involvement, we think of somebody for whom politics is front and center. It is something that they think about on a daily basis. It's something that they think about actually probably on an hourly basis. It is something that is a center to the way|||So, as you say, the deeply involved care a lot about politics, like Debbie Downer, they want to talk about politics, even to people who want to talk about something else. But you make a remarkable claim. You say the central fault line today in the United States might not be between Republicans and Democrats, but between people who are deeply involved in politics and everybody else, what do you mean by that? When we think about deep involvement, we think of somebody for whom politics is front and center. It is something that they think about on a daily basis. It's something that they think about actually probably on an hourly basis. It is something that is a center to the way
that they view the world. And so John Ryan and I, in describing these people and thinking about these people, conceive of them as being quite different from actually the majority of Americans and the majority of people. We see the fault line is how central you view politics to the world, how much attention you pay to politics, how you interpret political events, how much of an impact you believe that politics has in your life. And we see it as a fault line in the sense that for people who are deeply involved, politics
that they view the world. And so John Ryan and I, in describing these people and thinking about these people, conceive of them as being quite different from actually the majority of Americans and the majority of people. We see the fault line is how central you view politics to the world, how much attention you pay to politics, how you interpret political events, how much of an impact you believe that politics has in your life. And we see it as a fault line in the sense that for people who are deeply involved, politics|||that they view the world. And so John Ryan and I, in describing these people and thinking about these people, conceive of them as being quite different from actually the majority of Americans and the majority of people. We see the fault line is how central you view politics to the world, how much attention you pay to politics, how you interpret political events, how much of an impact you believe that politics has in your life. And we see it as a fault line in the sense that for people who are deeply involved, politics
is of such profound importance that it dominates the world perspective, it dominates how they view others, it dominates what they do with their day. And we see that as being profoundly different from a large group of Americans for whom politics is less important and for whom politics seems more as something that is happening on the side, something that is potentially troubling, something that is potentially problematic, but something that they don't necessarily want to think about all that much. I want to spend some time talking about the characteristics of the people you describe as deeply involved, because of course it's one thing to say this is a distinct group,
is of such profound importance that it dominates the world perspective, it dominates how they view others, it dominates what they do with their day. And we see that as being profoundly different from a large group of Americans for whom politics is less important and for whom politics seems more as something that is happening on the side, something that is potentially troubling, something that is potentially problematic, but something that they don't necessarily want to think about all that much. I want to spend some time talking about the characteristics of the people you describe as deeply involved, because of course it's one thing to say this is a distinct group,|||is of such profound importance that it dominates the world perspective, it dominates how they view others, it dominates what they do with their day. And we see that as being profoundly different from a large group of Americans for whom politics is less important and for whom politics seems more as something that is happening on the side, something that is potentially troubling, something that is potentially problematic, but something that they don't necessarily want to think about all that much. I want to spend some time talking about the characteristics of the people you describe as deeply involved, because of course it's one thing to say this is a distinct group,
but you go further than that. Through a series of surveys and experiments involving thousands of Americans, you find the deeply involved have a set of very distinct characteristics. And the first identifier is something that you hinted at a second ago. These are people who spend a lot of time on politics. Yes, when we think about the deeply involved, we think about a set of psychological characteristics that lead somebody to sort of really care about politics
but you go further than that. Through a series of surveys and experiments involving thousands of Americans, you find the deeply involved have a set of very distinct characteristics. And the first identifier is something that you hinted at a second ago. These are people who spend a lot of time on politics. Yes, when we think about the deeply involved, we think about a set of psychological characteristics that lead somebody to sort of really care about politics|||but you go further than that. Through a series of surveys and experiments involving thousands of Americans, you find the deeply involved have a set of very distinct characteristics. And the first identifier is something that you hinted at a second ago. These are people who spend a lot of time on politics. Yes, when we think about the deeply involved, we think about a set of psychological characteristics that lead somebody to sort of really care about politics
to think about it a ton. In fact, for a research, we began with the psychology of people who are our fans of things. And one of the things that emerges when you think about something being important to you is time. Why would you spend time on something that's not important to you? Obviously, what makes this a particularly unique moment for these people is now you actually can spend a tremendous amount of time on politics. You can basically wake up, you can unlock your phone, you can immediately start scrolling
to think about it a ton. In fact, for a research, we began with the psychology of people who are our fans of things. And one of the things that emerges when you think about something being important to you is time. Why would you spend time on something that's not important to you? Obviously, what makes this a particularly unique moment for these people is now you actually can spend a tremendous amount of time on politics. You can basically wake up, you can unlock your phone, you can immediately start scrolling|||to think about it a ton. In fact, for a research, we began with the psychology of people who are our fans of things. And one of the things that emerges when you think about something being important to you is time. Why would you spend time on something that's not important to you? Obviously, what makes this a particularly unique moment for these people is now you actually can spend a tremendous amount of time on politics. You can basically wake up, you can unlock your phone, you can immediately start scrolling
through the news, and you can basically be connected to politics for your entire day. Another trait of the deeply involved on both sides of the political spectrum is that they're interested in minor political developments. They see deep significance in events that may or may not be important. One example is this reaction on CNN after President Trump tweeted a made-up word in the middle of the night. The Coféfe tweet that Mercurial late-night presidential sentence fragment with one of the best words stayed up with no explanation for hours and hours and hours and then as dawn broke the president suddenly deleted it and wrote quote who could figure out the true meaning of kofefe i remember watching
through the news, and you can basically be connected to politics for your entire day. Another trait of the deeply involved on both sides of the political spectrum is that they're interested in minor political developments. They see deep significance in events that may or may not be important. One example is this reaction on CNN after President Trump tweeted a made-up word in the middle of the night. The Coféfe tweet that Mercurial late-night presidential sentence fragment with one of the best words stayed up with no explanation for hours and hours and hours and then as dawn broke the president suddenly deleted it and wrote quote who could figure out the true meaning of kofefe i remember watching|||through the news, and you can basically be connected to politics for your entire day. Another trait of the deeply involved on both sides of the political spectrum is that they're interested in minor political developments. They see deep significance in events that may or may not be important. One example is this reaction on CNN after President Trump tweeted a made-up word in the middle of the night. The Coféfe tweet that Mercurial late-night presidential sentence fragment with one of the best words stayed up with no explanation for hours and hours and hours and then as dawn broke the president suddenly deleted it and wrote quote who could figure out the true meaning of kofefe i remember watching
the story on and getting a laugh out of it but i also remember people going on about how the tweet might reflect a neurodegenerative disorder in the president they were taking this really, really seriously. And I think that is sort of profound. The Kaffee-Fee tweet is in some sense, I think, a profound example of deep involvement. This thing happens. This thing that is ostensibly ridiculous, right? It's obviously a typo, but it becomes something that is of import to people.
the story on and getting a laugh out of it but i also remember people going on about how the tweet might reflect a neurodegenerative disorder in the president they were taking this really, really seriously. And I think that is sort of profound. The Kaffee-Fee tweet is in some sense, I think, a profound example of deep involvement. This thing happens. This thing that is ostensibly ridiculous, right? It's obviously a typo, but it becomes something that is of import to people.|||the story on and getting a laugh out of it but i also remember people going on about how the tweet might reflect a neurodegenerative disorder in the president they were taking this really, really seriously. And I think that is sort of profound. The Kaffee-Fee tweet is in some sense, I think, a profound example of deep involvement. This thing happens. This thing that is ostensibly ridiculous, right? It's obviously a typo, but it becomes something that is of import to people.
There are people who are anxious that they missed this tweet. There are people wondering what this tweet means. And as people think about it more, especially people who are deeply engaged in politics, they start to make more and more connections to political events. Is it something meaningful? Is it something about the president? What's going to happen next? And the reality about politics is that a lot of what happens in politics is, in fact, a matter of life and death. We've learned this in a fairly profound way this summer. But for the deeply involved, even typo tweets
There are people who are anxious that they missed this tweet. There are people wondering what this tweet means. And as people think about it more, especially people who are deeply engaged in politics, they start to make more and more connections to political events. Is it something meaningful? Is it something about the president? What's going to happen next? And the reality about politics is that a lot of what happens in politics is, in fact, a matter of life and death. We've learned this in a fairly profound way this summer. But for the deeply involved, even typo tweets|||There are people who are anxious that they missed this tweet. There are people wondering what this tweet means. And as people think about it more, especially people who are deeply engaged in politics, they start to make more and more connections to political events. Is it something meaningful? Is it something about the president? What's going to happen next? And the reality about politics is that a lot of what happens in politics is, in fact, a matter of life and death. We've learned this in a fairly profound way this summer. But for the deeply involved, even typo tweets
But for the deeply involved, even typo tweets can become something that is actually very, very, very important. And that sort of makes sense. If you spend so much time with politics, if you spend so much time following it, you know enough where almost everything can be of profound importance. Where the president making a typo could be a signal of just kind of what's to come, something about the political state of the world. So for the deeply involved,
But for the deeply involved, even typo tweets can become something that is actually very, very, very important. And that sort of makes sense. If you spend so much time with politics, if you spend so much time following it, you know enough where almost everything can be of profound importance. Where the president making a typo could be a signal of just kind of what's to come, something about the political state of the world. So for the deeply involved,|||But for the deeply involved, even typo tweets can become something that is actually very, very, very important. And that sort of makes sense. If you spend so much time with politics, if you spend so much time following it, you know enough where almost everything can be of profound importance. Where the president making a typo could be a signal of just kind of what's to come, something about the political state of the world. So for the deeply involved,
the engagement with politics kind of contributes to the perception that any next event could be the event that kind of changes everything. In other words, the deeply involved follow politics in the same way that some people follow a favorite sports team or the twists and turns in a beloved TV show. Yana draws an analogy between people who are deeply involved in politics and fans of the sci-fi show, Dr. Who.
the engagement with politics kind of contributes to the perception that any next event could be the event that kind of changes everything. In other words, the deeply involved follow politics in the same way that some people follow a favorite sports team or the twists and turns in a beloved TV show. Yana draws an analogy between people who are deeply involved in politics and fans of the sci-fi show, Dr. Who.|||the engagement with politics kind of contributes to the perception that any next event could be the event that kind of changes everything. In other words, the deeply involved follow politics in the same way that some people follow a favorite sports team or the twists and turns in a beloved TV show. Yana draws an analogy between people who are deeply involved in politics and fans of the sci-fi show, Dr. Who.
Multiple actors portray the doctor in the television show. And for years, fans have argued obsessively about which actor is the best doctor. With the exception of the very bottom slot, which we'll get to in a second, I don't think there is a bad version of the doctor. What's the connection between Doctor Who, Efficient Adios, and Politics, Yana? So Doctor Who, I think, is a really interesting kind of example, because in some sense, to have a favorite Doctor Who,
Multiple actors portray the doctor in the television show. And for years, fans have argued obsessively about which actor is the best doctor. With the exception of the very bottom slot, which we'll get to in a second, I don't think there is a bad version of the doctor. What's the connection between Doctor Who, Efficient Adios, and Politics, Yana? So Doctor Who, I think, is a really interesting kind of example, because in some sense, to have a favorite Doctor Who,|||Multiple actors portray the doctor in the television show. And for years, fans have argued obsessively about which actor is the best doctor. With the exception of the very bottom slot, which we'll get to in a second, I don't think there is a bad version of the doctor. What's the connection between Doctor Who, Efficient Adios, and Politics, Yana? So Doctor Who, I think, is a really interesting kind of example, because in some sense, to have a favorite Doctor Who,
you have to be a fan of the show. Because one of the beautiful things about Doctor Who is everyone gets to have their Doctor, your pick does not have to be anyone else's, you do not have to rank them the way anyone else does. Somebody who does not have a favorite doctor who is probably not a huge fan of the show, or maybe a more peripheral fan of the show. And so what your criticism is, when you criticize somebody's favorite doctor pick, is that they are involved, but they are involved in the wrong way. So, starting at the bottom, Colin Baker. When we read research on this sort of support for the doctor,
you have to be a fan of the show. Because one of the beautiful things about Doctor Who is everyone gets to have their Doctor, your pick does not have to be anyone else's, you do not have to rank them the way anyone else does. Somebody who does not have a favorite doctor who is probably not a huge fan of the show, or maybe a more peripheral fan of the show. And so what your criticism is, when you criticize somebody's favorite doctor pick, is that they are involved, but they are involved in the wrong way. So, starting at the bottom, Colin Baker. When we read research on this sort of support for the doctor,|||you have to be a fan of the show. Because one of the beautiful things about Doctor Who is everyone gets to have their Doctor, your pick does not have to be anyone else's, you do not have to rank them the way anyone else does. Somebody who does not have a favorite doctor who is probably not a huge fan of the show, or maybe a more peripheral fan of the show. And so what your criticism is, when you criticize somebody's favorite doctor pick, is that they are involved, but they are involved in the wrong way. So, starting at the bottom, Colin Baker. When we read research on this sort of support for the doctor,
the psychology seemed almost similar to politics, of course, with much lower stakes. But there's the sense that somebody could be on your political side, but somebody could be on your political side. But they could be on your political side in not exactly the right way. And there is going to be something frustrating to somebody who is deeply involved. That this person is coming so close to getting it. But it's actually not there.
the psychology seemed almost similar to politics, of course, with much lower stakes. But there's the sense that somebody could be on your political side, but somebody could be on your political side. But they could be on your political side in not exactly the right way. And there is going to be something frustrating to somebody who is deeply involved. That this person is coming so close to getting it. But it's actually not there.|||the psychology seemed almost similar to politics, of course, with much lower stakes. But there's the sense that somebody could be on your political side, but somebody could be on your political side. But they could be on your political side in not exactly the right way. And there is going to be something frustrating to somebody who is deeply involved. That this person is coming so close to getting it. But it's actually not there.
There's another connection between Dr. Who fans and political fanatics. Neither can stop talking about their obsession. When we come back, how journalist's favor the zealous voices of the deeply involved. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Political scientist Yana Kripnikov argues that most Americans are not seeing the defining political fault line in the country. It's not Republican versus Democrat, but the gap between people who live, breathe, and talk politics all the time, and those for whom politics is a small part of their lives.
There's another connection between Dr. Who fans and political fanatics. Neither can stop talking about their obsession. When we come back, how journalist's favor the zealous voices of the deeply involved. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Political scientist Yana Kripnikov argues that most Americans are not seeing the defining political fault line in the country. It's not Republican versus Democrat, but the gap between people who live, breathe, and talk politics all the time, and those for whom politics is a small part of their lives.|||There's another connection between Dr. Who fans and political fanatics. Neither can stop talking about their obsession. When we come back, how journalist's favor the zealous voices of the deeply involved. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Political scientist Yana Kripnikov argues that most Americans are not seeing the defining political fault line in the country. It's not Republican versus Democrat, but the gap between people who live, breathe, and talk politics all the time, and those for whom politics is a small part of their lives.
The deeply involved spend lots of time learning about politics, thinking about politics. But they also do one other thing that the less engaged rarely do. Yada, you say the most defining feature of the people who are deeply involved in politics is something you call expression. What do you mean by that? When we think about expression, we mean the desire to communicate politics. We mean the desire to not just speak about information or speak about ways that you might change politics, but really expressing your own beliefs and feelings about politics. So really speaking your mind in the sense of something happens and you immediately want to tell others
The deeply involved spend lots of time learning about politics, thinking about politics. But they also do one other thing that the less engaged rarely do. Yada, you say the most defining feature of the people who are deeply involved in politics is something you call expression. What do you mean by that? When we think about expression, we mean the desire to communicate politics. We mean the desire to not just speak about information or speak about ways that you might change politics, but really expressing your own beliefs and feelings about politics. So really speaking your mind in the sense of something happens and you immediately want to tell others|||The deeply involved spend lots of time learning about politics, thinking about politics. But they also do one other thing that the less engaged rarely do. Yada, you say the most defining feature of the people who are deeply involved in politics is something you call expression. What do you mean by that? When we think about expression, we mean the desire to communicate politics. We mean the desire to not just speak about information or speak about ways that you might change politics, but really expressing your own beliefs and feelings about politics. So really speaking your mind in the sense of something happens and you immediately want to tell others
how you felt about it, whether it was good, how it made you think. But it's the idea of essentially expressing your views, expressing what others should do, just literally talking about what politics means to you. Now social media, you argue, is an important part of the story. How so? Well, in the past, if I wanted to talk to somebody about politics, I would have to find a person to literally talk about politics too. And maybe I couldn't find somebody to talk about politics to that day. And so I just wouldn't get to talk about it. Or maybe I found
how you felt about it, whether it was good, how it made you think. But it's the idea of essentially expressing your views, expressing what others should do, just literally talking about what politics means to you. Now social media, you argue, is an important part of the story. How so? Well, in the past, if I wanted to talk to somebody about politics, I would have to find a person to literally talk about politics too. And maybe I couldn't find somebody to talk about politics to that day. And so I just wouldn't get to talk about it. Or maybe I found|||how you felt about it, whether it was good, how it made you think. But it's the idea of essentially expressing your views, expressing what others should do, just literally talking about what politics means to you. Now social media, you argue, is an important part of the story. How so? Well, in the past, if I wanted to talk to somebody about politics, I would have to find a person to literally talk about politics too. And maybe I couldn't find somebody to talk about politics to that day. And so I just wouldn't get to talk about it. Or maybe I found
a friend and I just told him all about my political feelings and they just didn't really care. and they just didn't really care. But now, if I can go to Twitter and I can type a political opinion. I just changed the channel from Trump Town Hall to the Biden Town Hall and immediately fell asleep. There is a high probability that a number of people will chime in. Oh my God, it was so boring.
a friend and I just told him all about my political feelings and they just didn't really care. and they just didn't really care. But now, if I can go to Twitter and I can type a political opinion. I just changed the channel from Trump Town Hall to the Biden Town Hall and immediately fell asleep. There is a high probability that a number of people will chime in. Oh my God, it was so boring.|||a friend and I just told him all about my political feelings and they just didn't really care. and they just didn't really care. But now, if I can go to Twitter and I can type a political opinion. I just changed the channel from Trump Town Hall to the Biden Town Hall and immediately fell asleep. There is a high probability that a number of people will chime in. Oh my God, it was so boring.
I need to support Trump 100%. And potentially a lot of them might tell me that I'm like, it was like listening to Grandpa. It taped Biden's town hall to help me fall asleep. And certainly, because it's Twitter, it's possible that a bunch of people will also chime in and tell me that I am a terrible person. I'm pretty sure America could do with a good business.
I need to support Trump 100%. And potentially a lot of them might tell me that I'm like, it was like listening to Grandpa. It taped Biden's town hall to help me fall asleep. And certainly, because it's Twitter, it's possible that a bunch of people will also chime in and tell me that I am a terrible person. I'm pretty sure America could do with a good business.|||I need to support Trump 100%. And potentially a lot of them might tell me that I'm like, it was like listening to Grandpa. It taped Biden's town hall to help me fall asleep. And certainly, because it's Twitter, it's possible that a bunch of people will also chime in and tell me that I am a terrible person. I'm pretty sure America could do with a good business.
I'm not my ballot for Joe Biden. You can roll up the net to entertain its people or to protect them. But at least there will be somebody who allows me that expression. You have a story about social media from your own life that isn't about politics, but it says so much about how many of us I think engage with politics. Can you tell me the story of your toddler and the plane trip? Yes, so my daughter and I were on a flight and my husband was there as well.
I'm not my ballot for Joe Biden. You can roll up the net to entertain its people or to protect them. But at least there will be somebody who allows me that expression. You have a story about social media from your own life that isn't about politics, but it says so much about how many of us I think engage with politics. Can you tell me the story of your toddler and the plane trip? Yes, so my daughter and I were on a flight and my husband was there as well.|||I'm not my ballot for Joe Biden. You can roll up the net to entertain its people or to protect them. But at least there will be somebody who allows me that expression. You have a story about social media from your own life that isn't about politics, but it says so much about how many of us I think engage with politics. Can you tell me the story of your toddler and the plane trip? Yes, so my daughter and I were on a flight and my husband was there as well.
My daughter was about one and a half at the time. It was a seven hour flight. My daughter was basically being herself. She was being a one and a half year old. And into this flight I started noticing this woman ahead of us would constantly just turn every time my daughter would make a slight noise. And this frustrated me. This made me quite upset. And it's this feeling of am I doing a terrible job, am I a terrible parent? Why does this woman keep turning around as my kid being this bad? And so I did the first thing that came to my mind.
My daughter was about one and a half at the time. It was a seven hour flight. My daughter was basically being herself. She was being a one and a half year old. And into this flight I started noticing this woman ahead of us would constantly just turn every time my daughter would make a slight noise. And this frustrated me. This made me quite upset. And it's this feeling of am I doing a terrible job, am I a terrible parent? Why does this woman keep turning around as my kid being this bad? And so I did the first thing that came to my mind.|||My daughter was about one and a half at the time. It was a seven hour flight. My daughter was basically being herself. She was being a one and a half year old. And into this flight I started noticing this woman ahead of us would constantly just turn every time my daughter would make a slight noise. And this frustrated me. This made me quite upset. And it's this feeling of am I doing a terrible job, am I a terrible parent? Why does this woman keep turning around as my kid being this bad? And so I did the first thing that came to my mind.
I paid for internet so I could go to Twitter. And I tweeted about the fact that I'm on this light and this woman keeps turning around and just looking at my daughter. And the thing is, I want to emphasize here that it was pretty safe for me to tweet that. I knew pretty much what my network was like. Immediately, the replies kept pouring in, telling me
I paid for internet so I could go to Twitter. And I tweeted about the fact that I'm on this light and this woman keeps turning around and just looking at my daughter. And the thing is, I want to emphasize here that it was pretty safe for me to tweet that. I knew pretty much what my network was like. Immediately, the replies kept pouring in, telling me|||I paid for internet so I could go to Twitter. And I tweeted about the fact that I'm on this light and this woman keeps turning around and just looking at my daughter. And the thing is, I want to emphasize here that it was pretty safe for me to tweet that. I knew pretty much what my network was like. Immediately, the replies kept pouring in, telling me
that it was definitely not me, that it was definitely her. In fact, I think it was one of the most engaged tweets, right? I don't get that much engagement when I tweet about my research. And in that moment, so two things happened. So first, I felt really good. It was actually very good to have this social support from a bunch of internet people. The second thing is that it made me just
that it was definitely not me, that it was definitely her. In fact, I think it was one of the most engaged tweets, right? I don't get that much engagement when I tweet about my research. And in that moment, so two things happened. So first, I felt really good. It was actually very good to have this social support from a bunch of internet people. The second thing is that it made me just|||that it was definitely not me, that it was definitely her. In fact, I think it was one of the most engaged tweets, right? I don't get that much engagement when I tweet about my research. And in that moment, so two things happened. So first, I felt really good. It was actually very good to have this social support from a bunch of internet people. The second thing is that it made me just
much anger at this woman because it was this kind of feeling of all these people on the internet think that you're a wrong airplane lady and they're telling me that I am right. Eventually the seven-hour flight is over. The plane lands and Janus' husband takes his phone off airplane mode and goes to Twitter where he sees his wife's tweet storm. And he was actually really surprised. He did not notice the woman, even though she was actually more in his eyesight than mine. He did not see her turning around at any point. He thought everything had gone really well.
much anger at this woman because it was this kind of feeling of all these people on the internet think that you're a wrong airplane lady and they're telling me that I am right. Eventually the seven-hour flight is over. The plane lands and Janus' husband takes his phone off airplane mode and goes to Twitter where he sees his wife's tweet storm. And he was actually really surprised. He did not notice the woman, even though she was actually more in his eyesight than mine. He did not see her turning around at any point. He thought everything had gone really well.|||much anger at this woman because it was this kind of feeling of all these people on the internet think that you're a wrong airplane lady and they're telling me that I am right. Eventually the seven-hour flight is over. The plane lands and Janus' husband takes his phone off airplane mode and goes to Twitter where he sees his wife's tweet storm. And he was actually really surprised. He did not notice the woman, even though she was actually more in his eyesight than mine. He did not see her turning around at any point. He thought everything had gone really well.
And it was a sort of a notable moment. I had had this moment, I went to Twitter. By virtue of going to Twitter, it all kind of got a bit exacerbated. And yet here was somebody sitting next to me who had no idea what I was talking about. He didn't notice anything at all. And I can see the really wonderful metaphor here with the way our politics unfolds on social media and the way we so many of us engage with politics on social media. But there's also something of a mystery here. You say that the people who are deeply involved are a minority of all Americans. So why is it, Yana, that we feel
And it was a sort of a notable moment. I had had this moment, I went to Twitter. By virtue of going to Twitter, it all kind of got a bit exacerbated. And yet here was somebody sitting next to me who had no idea what I was talking about. He didn't notice anything at all. And I can see the really wonderful metaphor here with the way our politics unfolds on social media and the way we so many of us engage with politics on social media. But there's also something of a mystery here. You say that the people who are deeply involved are a minority of all Americans. So why is it, Yana, that we feel|||And it was a sort of a notable moment. I had had this moment, I went to Twitter. By virtue of going to Twitter, it all kind of got a bit exacerbated. And yet here was somebody sitting next to me who had no idea what I was talking about. He didn't notice anything at all. And I can see the really wonderful metaphor here with the way our politics unfolds on social media and the way we so many of us engage with politics on social media. But there's also something of a mystery here. You say that the people who are deeply involved are a minority of all Americans. So why is it, Yana, that we feel
like we hear their voices all the time? We hear the deeply involved because they are actually very loud. And I don't mean that they're necessarily screaming. But I mean that in the sense that they are more likely to occupy our social media feeds. Their voices are more likely to be talking about politics. So it seems like they're everywhere because whenever we encounter politics, it is quite often the voices of these people who are very, very deeply involved. And so if you're constantly seeing these posts about politics, you might not realize that they are from a very small set of people, or you might think to yourself, well, I guess I'm the odd person out.
like we hear their voices all the time? We hear the deeply involved because they are actually very loud. And I don't mean that they're necessarily screaming. But I mean that in the sense that they are more likely to occupy our social media feeds. Their voices are more likely to be talking about politics. So it seems like they're everywhere because whenever we encounter politics, it is quite often the voices of these people who are very, very deeply involved. And so if you're constantly seeing these posts about politics, you might not realize that they are from a very small set of people, or you might think to yourself, well, I guess I'm the odd person out.|||like we hear their voices all the time? We hear the deeply involved because they are actually very loud. And I don't mean that they're necessarily screaming. But I mean that in the sense that they are more likely to occupy our social media feeds. Their voices are more likely to be talking about politics. So it seems like they're everywhere because whenever we encounter politics, it is quite often the voices of these people who are very, very deeply involved. And so if you're constantly seeing these posts about politics, you might not realize that they are from a very small set of people, or you might think to yourself, well, I guess I'm the odd person out.
I never talk about politics, but I guess everyone else is. And so you kind of come to this idea that the politically involved are much more around us than they actually are in numbers. Yana, you also make the case that one reason we hear the voices of the deeply involved everywhere is because journalists have a deep affinity for the voices of the deeply involved. Why is this?
I never talk about politics, but I guess everyone else is. And so you kind of come to this idea that the politically involved are much more around us than they actually are in numbers. Yana, you also make the case that one reason we hear the voices of the deeply involved everywhere is because journalists have a deep affinity for the voices of the deeply involved. Why is this?|||I never talk about politics, but I guess everyone else is. And so you kind of come to this idea that the politically involved are much more around us than they actually are in numbers. Yana, you also make the case that one reason we hear the voices of the deeply involved everywhere is because journalists have a deep affinity for the voices of the deeply involved. Why is this?
If we think about what media coverage includes, it's a lot of conflict, and the deeply involved are kind of readily there to provide the conflict. They're gonna be the people who can be most critical of the other side, they're gonna be the people who are gonna talk most passionately about politics. And so it sort of follows that journalists are
If we think about what media coverage includes, it's a lot of conflict, and the deeply involved are kind of readily there to provide the conflict. They're gonna be the people who can be most critical of the other side, they're gonna be the people who are gonna talk most passionately about politics. And so it sort of follows that journalists are|||If we think about what media coverage includes, it's a lot of conflict, and the deeply involved are kind of readily there to provide the conflict. They're gonna be the people who can be most critical of the other side, they're gonna be the people who are gonna talk most passionately about politics. And so it sort of follows that journalists are
going to be heavily drawn to people who are deeply involved. And so part and parcel of this coverage is actually coverage of political polarization. If journalists are drawn to coverage of political polarization, then they are almost by definition going to be drawn to the voices of the deeply involved. And so they come to dominate these stories as examples of just how terrible partisan relations are. Yana has run studies with hundreds of journalists across the United States. She has asked them the marriage question we discussed earlier. How many Americans
going to be heavily drawn to people who are deeply involved. And so part and parcel of this coverage is actually coverage of political polarization. If journalists are drawn to coverage of political polarization, then they are almost by definition going to be drawn to the voices of the deeply involved. And so they come to dominate these stories as examples of just how terrible partisan relations are. Yana has run studies with hundreds of journalists across the United States. She has asked them the marriage question we discussed earlier. How many Americans|||going to be heavily drawn to people who are deeply involved. And so part and parcel of this coverage is actually coverage of political polarization. If journalists are drawn to coverage of political polarization, then they are almost by definition going to be drawn to the voices of the deeply involved. And so they come to dominate these stories as examples of just how terrible partisan relations are. Yana has run studies with hundreds of journalists across the United States. She has asked them the marriage question we discussed earlier. How many Americans
would be unhappy if that child married someone from the opposing political party? And what we found is that journalists vastly overestimated this level of polarization. They believe that something like half of Americans would be quite profoundly polarized. When it is actually not the case, when we look over our sample, it was a tremendous kind of difference between what journalists suspected was the case, and what actually was the case in our sample. Many journalists also have a love affair with Twitter. What did they see when they get on their feeds? The people who love to talk about politics.
would be unhappy if that child married someone from the opposing political party? And what we found is that journalists vastly overestimated this level of polarization. They believe that something like half of Americans would be quite profoundly polarized. When it is actually not the case, when we look over our sample, it was a tremendous kind of difference between what journalists suspected was the case, and what actually was the case in our sample. Many journalists also have a love affair with Twitter. What did they see when they get on their feeds? The people who love to talk about politics.|||would be unhappy if that child married someone from the opposing political party? And what we found is that journalists vastly overestimated this level of polarization. They believe that something like half of Americans would be quite profoundly polarized. When it is actually not the case, when we look over our sample, it was a tremendous kind of difference between what journalists suspected was the case, and what actually was the case in our sample. Many journalists also have a love affair with Twitter. What did they see when they get on their feeds? The people who love to talk about politics.
There's this fascinating work by scholar Shannon McGregor that shows the journalists are often turning to Twitter as a gauge of public opinion. Well, if the deeply involved are much more likely to express themselves on Twitter, and if journalists are looking to Twitter for stories for public opinion, they are certainly having a higher probability of landing on the opinions of the deeply involved and then elevating those perceptions to stories on polarization of stories of discord, of stories of violence. Does the fact that many journalists themselves live and work in communities of deep involvement in politics play a role in this as well?
There's this fascinating work by scholar Shannon McGregor that shows the journalists are often turning to Twitter as a gauge of public opinion. Well, if the deeply involved are much more likely to express themselves on Twitter, and if journalists are looking to Twitter for stories for public opinion, they are certainly having a higher probability of landing on the opinions of the deeply involved and then elevating those perceptions to stories on polarization of stories of discord, of stories of violence. Does the fact that many journalists themselves live and work in communities of deep involvement in politics play a role in this as well?|||There's this fascinating work by scholar Shannon McGregor that shows the journalists are often turning to Twitter as a gauge of public opinion. Well, if the deeply involved are much more likely to express themselves on Twitter, and if journalists are looking to Twitter for stories for public opinion, they are certainly having a higher probability of landing on the opinions of the deeply involved and then elevating those perceptions to stories on polarization of stories of discord, of stories of violence. Does the fact that many journalists themselves live and work in communities of deep involvement in politics play a role in this as well?
I mean, I'm thinking of journalists certainly within the Washington Beltway, their embedded in communities and neighborhoods where lots of their friends and neighbors are probably among the ranks of the deeply involved? I would think that it does. When I think of myself, for example, when I log on to Twitter, I am in a network of people who are deeply involved in politics. And so often, it's almost difficult for me to remember
I mean, I'm thinking of journalists certainly within the Washington Beltway, their embedded in communities and neighborhoods where lots of their friends and neighbors are probably among the ranks of the deeply involved? I would think that it does. When I think of myself, for example, when I log on to Twitter, I am in a network of people who are deeply involved in politics. And so often, it's almost difficult for me to remember|||I mean, I'm thinking of journalists certainly within the Washington Beltway, their embedded in communities and neighborhoods where lots of their friends and neighbors are probably among the ranks of the deeply involved? I would think that it does. When I think of myself, for example, when I log on to Twitter, I am in a network of people who are deeply involved in politics. And so often, it's almost difficult for me to remember
that there are all these people in my own survey data for whom politics is actually much, much less important. And I imagine for journalists it actually must be exacerbated. They're also in these kinds of networks. They're often in networks with other journalists. So essentially there's constantly somebody there reinforcing your view of what is important and what politics looks like and what the world looks like. And so in that sense, it is a perspective of the world that is actually completely in line
that there are all these people in my own survey data for whom politics is actually much, much less important. And I imagine for journalists it actually must be exacerbated. They're also in these kinds of networks. They're often in networks with other journalists. So essentially there's constantly somebody there reinforcing your view of what is important and what politics looks like and what the world looks like. And so in that sense, it is a perspective of the world that is actually completely in line|||that there are all these people in my own survey data for whom politics is actually much, much less important. And I imagine for journalists it actually must be exacerbated. They're also in these kinds of networks. They're often in networks with other journalists. So essentially there's constantly somebody there reinforcing your view of what is important and what politics looks like and what the world looks like. And so in that sense, it is a perspective of the world that is actually completely in line
with the world you see around you, but the world you see around you may not necessarily be reflective of a large group of people. One of the most troubling things that took away from your work is how privilege might intersect with political involvement. The person working three jobs to make ends meet, it's probably not the person who really cares that the president was up at night tweeting made up words. Many working parents, you know, they might be too exhausted with work and childcare to be up in arms about the latest Buhaha on Twitter. So when we
而你周围看到的世界，并不一定能反映出一大群人的真实面貌。你研究中最令人不安的发现之一，就是特权如何与政治参与交织在一起。那个为了维持生计而打三份工的人，可能根本不在乎总统大晚上发推特编造新词。许多工作的父母，你知道的，他们可能已经对工作和照顾孩子感到精疲力竭，无暇去对推特上的最新闹剧感到愤怒。所以当我们在
privilege the voices of the deeply involved, at some level are we also privileging the voices of the privileged? I think there are two ways to look at it. On the one hand, I think there is a certain privilege to not following politics, where you sort of feel so comfortable about your state in the country that you don't necessarily care who wins. But I think there's another privilege, and that is spending a lot of time following politics. I feel like I have a tremendous amount of privilege in my job that I can check in and see what's happening on the news. That I'm afforded the flexibility to do so.
赋予那些高度投入的人更多声音时，在某种程度上，我们是否也在赋予特权阶层声音？我认为可以从两个方面来看。一方面，我认为不关注政治本身也是一种特权，你会对自己在国内的现状感到足够舒适，以至于不那么在意谁能赢得大选。但我认为还有另一种特权，那就是花大量时间关注政治。我觉得我的工作给了我巨大的特权，让我可以随时查看新闻了解发生了什么，我有这样的灵活性。
That I can follow a debate or that I can follow a congressional hearing, for example, if I so chose. But when I think about the world of people who are working hourly jobs, who are single parents, who are basically living kind of paycheck to paycheck, politics may not be something they just have time for. Spending a lot of time figuring out the latest presidential tweet is not necessarily going to be something that when they have downtime, they're going to be able to do, right? They probably rather spend time with their kids or their families.
例如，如果我愿意，我可以关注一场辩论或一场国会听证会。但当我想到那些从事按小时计酬的工作、单亲父母、基本上过着月光族生活的人们时，政治可能并不是他们有时间去关注的事情。花大量时间研究总统的最新推特，并不一定是他们在有空闲时间时会去做的事，对吧？他们可能更愿意把时间花在孩子或家人身上。
So I think there is certainly a privilege to actually being able to spend the time on politics that I think a lot of people in this country just don't have. What effects do people who are deeply involved in politics have on our larger discourse, on our ability to find solutions and make compromises? That's when we come back. People who are deeply involved in politics have strong convictions. They talk about politics all the time because they are worried about the state of the country, the economy, they care. They believe that if they can only get other Americans to care as much as they do, we would
所以，我认为能够真正花时间在政治上绝对是一种特权，而这个国家的许多人根本没有这种特权。那些高度参与政治的人，对我们更大的社会讨论、对我们寻找解决方案和妥协的能力，会产生什么影响？我们稍后回来解答。高度参与政治的人有着坚定的信念。他们无时无刻不在谈论政治，因为他们关心国家和经济的现状，他们真的在乎。他们坚信，只要能让其他美国人像他们一样在乎，我们的生活
all be better off. So are they succeeding? Yana, people who are deeply involved in politics want to engage people who are not involved because they want to affect change. They want others to see the importance of political issues and political causes. Are they effective at doing this? So I think the goals of the deeply evolved are actually coming from a good place.
都会变得更好。那么，他们成功了吗？雅娜，高度参与政治的人想要吸引那些不参与的人，因为他们想要带来改变。他们希望其他人看到政治议题和政治原因的重要性。他们在做这件事时有效吗？所以，我认为高度投入者的目标其实出发点是好的。
If you are looking over the spectrum of politics and you see things happening in front of you that you think are horrifying, and terrible, and problematic, you want other people to know about this. You want other people to know that they should be anxious and they should be afraid and bad things could be coming. But I think there is the sense of deep involvement that may not necessarily translate to others.
如果你审视整个政治光谱，看到眼前发生的种种事情，并且认为它们是可怕的、糟糕的、有问题的，你就会想让其他人知道这一点。你想让其他人知道他们应该感到焦虑、感到害怕，糟糕的事情可能即将降临。但我认为，这种深度参与感可能无法很好地向他人传递。
When others see somebody who is profoundly involved in politics, it might send the message that to be at all engaged, that is how you should behave. That it's not enough to just kind of sporadically follow the news or to pay attention during elections, but you have to sort of live and breathe politics, And that's how you become somebody who is politically engaged or knows anything political. And I think that's tough for people. I think for people who may not necessarily have the time or the strong interest, believing that this is how political engagement works,
当其他人看到一个对政治极其投入的人时，可能会传达这样一种信息：要想参与其中，你就必须这样表现。仅仅零星地关注新闻或在选举期间关注一下是不够的，你必须把政治当成生活和呼吸的一部分，这才是成为一个政治参与者或懂政治的人的唯一方式。我认为这对人们来说很难。我想对于那些不一定有时间或强烈兴趣的人来说，相信这就是政治参与的方式，
may be kind of a tough example to swallow, which I think can undermine the effectiveness of those who are politically involved, encouraging others to become more engaged as well. So, there's a very interesting psychological theory that you're advancing here. In some ways, you're saying the deeply involved in some ways have become our role models of how it is to be involved in politics. And when we look at the deeply involved, when we turn on cable news in the evenings, and we hear them, we turn on Twitter, and we watch sort of the debates raging on Twitter,
可能会让人有点难以接受，我认为这会削弱那些积极参与政治的人鼓励其他人也更多参与的效果。所以，你在这里提出了一个非常有趣的心理学理论。在某种程度上，你是在说高度投入的人在某些方面已经成为了我们参与政治的榜样。当我们看着这些高度投入的人，当我们在傍晚打开有线新闻听到他们的声音，打开推特看到推特上激烈的辩论时，
we think this is how, if you're interested in politics, this is how you have to be involved in politics. And then we ask ourselves the question, do I want to be that kind of person? And what you're saying is for many people, the answer might be no. Yeah, a lot of times when we categorize ourselves, this research and psychology suggests we compare ourselves to other people, and we sort of say, am I like this person? Am I similar to this person?
我们就会想，如果你对政治感兴趣，你就必须以这种方式参与政治。然后我们会问自己一个问题：我想成为那种人吗？而你的意思对许多人来说，答案可能是否定的。是的，很多时候当我们对自我进行分类时，心理学研究表明我们会将自己与其他人进行比较，我们会问自己：我像这个人吗？我跟这个人相似吗？
In what ways that I'm different? And I think in some sense when people compare themselves to the deeply involved, they're obviously going to see that they I'm different. And I think in some sense, when people compare themselves to the deeply involved, they're obviously going to see that they are quite different. Maybe they're going to think, I don't feel quite as strongly. Or I vote in these national elections, but I can't bring myself to vote in these local elections. I just don't know enough.
我们在哪些方面不同？我认为在某种程度上，当人们将自己与高度投入的人进行比较时，他们显然会看到自己与他们有所不同。或许他们会想，我的感触没有那么深。或者我在这些全国性选举中投票，但我无法强迫自己在这些地方选举中投票。我只是了解得不够多。
And that contributes to our self-categorization, as somebody who is ostensibly non-political, which is I think a descriptor actually hear quite a lot from people. I'm not political. And I think an interesting question there becomes, are you not political or are you not deeply involved? Are you actually entirely disengaged from politics? Or do you just not believe that you have any capacity to be part of politics because you don't think you can look like the people you see on your television screen? I'm wondering if there's another effect here, which is that if I'm a Democrat and I'm watching
这促使我们将自己归类为表面上不关心政治的人，我想这个词我经常从人们那里听到。我不是个政治迷。我认为这里产生的一个有趣问题是：你是不关心政治，还是没有深度投入？你是完全脱离了政治，还是仅仅不相信自己有能力参与政治，因为你觉得自己看起来不像电视屏幕上看到的那样？我想知道这里是否还有另一个效应，那就是如果我是一个民主党人，正在看着
television and I'm seeing people who are deeply involved in politics, who are Republicans on television, it's reasonable almost for me to draw the impression that all Republicans must be like the Republicans that I see on television. And in fact, some research I've recently done suggests that very point. So along with co-authors, Samaritan, Clark, John Ryan, Jamie Druckerman, and Matt Levin Dusky, we actually asked people what they believe the most common member of the opposing party looks like. And then we actually measured what people from both parties look like. And what we found is that people imagined
电视，看到那些深度参与政治、在电视上作为共和党人出现的人，我几乎很自然地会产生一种印象：所有的共和党人都一定像我在电视上看到的那些共和党人一样。事实上，我最近做的一些研究就表明了这一点。因此，我和合著者萨马拉·克拉克、约翰·瑞安、杰米·德鲁克曼以及马特·莱文杜斯基一起，实际上询问了人们他们认为反对党中最典型成员长什么样。然后我们实际测量了两党成员的长相。我们发现，人们想象中
that those from the other party were constantly talking about politics and that they were very extreme. But in fact, that's not the case at all. The sort of most common member of a party, a person on a survey who says they're a Democrat or a Republican, is somebody who doesn't talk about politics all that much, and somebody who's not all that extreme.
对方政党的人总是喋喋不休地谈论政治，而且非常极端。但事实上，情况根本不是这样的。政党中最常见的成员——也就是在调查中自称民主党人或共和党人的人——其实是一个并不怎么谈论政治、也不是那么极端的人。
And so the difference between what the partisans actually look like and what people imagine the partisans actually look like was quite jarring. But it's not as jarring when you think about the partisans that you see on Twitter, the partisans that you see on television, the partisans you see in the news. Of people who are reasonable and dispassionate don't necessarily make for the best political
因此，党派人士实际的模样与人们想象中党派人士的模样之间存在着相当大的差距。但当你想到你在推特上看到的党派人士、在电视上看到的党派人士、在新闻中看到的党派人士时，这种差距就没那么惊人了。那些理性而冷静的人不一定能构成最好的政治
news, especially if you want to illustrate polarization. And so when we see people who are quite angry, it forms our idea of what a partisan is and what somebody who is political actually looks like. When I look at the voter turnout in recent elections, the biggest party by far might not be the Republican Party or the Democratic Party, it might be the party of what you might call, please leave me out of it. Among all Americans of voting age, about two and five, about 40% typically don't vote. Now this has been true for a long time. It probably
新闻，尤其是如果你想说明两极分化的话。因此，当我们看到那些非常愤怒的人时，它塑造了我们对一个党派人士以及一个关心政治的人的印象。当我查看最近几次选举的投票率时，迄今为止最大的政党可能不是共和党或民主党，它可能是那个你称之为“请别把我算进去”的政党。在所有达到投票年龄的美国人中，大约五分之二，即大约40%的人通常不投票。这种情况已经持续很长时间了。它可能
precedes the growth and popularity of social media. But is there a connection between the story you tell about this new fault line and people who are completely disengaging from politics? Well, this is a worry of mine when I think about deep involvement. If we sort of communicate to people that politics is about being angry, that politics is about essentially, and I don't just mean being angry about the events we see around us, because I think people should, in a lot of cases, be very angry about the political events we see around us. But essentially, the politics is constantly about fighting and spending a lot of time expressing this. It might suggest to people that they don't have what it takes to be a part of politics.
早于社交媒体的增长和普及。但是，你所讲述的关于这条新断层线的故事与那些完全脱离政治的人之间有什么联系吗？嗯，当我想到深度投入时，这就是我的担忧所在。如果我们向人们传达这样一种信息：政治就是关于愤怒，政治本质上就是——我指的不仅仅是对我们周围看到的事件感到愤怒，因为我认为在很多情况下，人们确实应该对我们周围看到的政治事件感到非常愤怒。但本质上，如果政治总是意味着争吵并花大量时间表达这种情绪，这可能会向人们暗示他们不具备参与政治的素质。
So when we think about people essentially disengaging, part of it might be people sort of saying, I don't necessarily want to be part of this. I don't want to be like partisans, I don't necessarily want to be in a group with these people I see around me. Yannis research finds that these people are not just reluctant to get involved in politics, they feel less confident in their ability to do so. If you think that you're non-political because you're different from those you see in the news, it might suggest to you that your voice is just not as worthwhile, and you might
因此，当我们想到人们实际上在脱离政治时，部分原因可能是人们在说，我不想卷入其中。我不想像那些党派人士一样，我也不一定想和我周围看到的这些人同流合污。雅娜的研究发现，这些人不仅不愿参与政治，他们对自己这样做的能力也感到信心不足。如果你认为自己不关心政治，是因为你与新闻中看到的人不同，这可能会让你觉得你的声音根本没有那么有价值，你甚至可能
actually even start to believe that you don't know enough to be part of the political world. You don't know enough to actually participate. Which I think could lead to people kind of exiting out of the process. Yeah. You cite a story that was once published in the New York Times about a woman who decided to sit out a recent election. She decided not to vote. And she had, I believe, friends or siblings who had very different feelings about what happened. Tell me that story. So, this story was quite interesting to us, and it was in the back of our minds as we
开始相信自己知道得太少，不足以成为政治世界的一部分。你所知甚少，无法真正参与其中。我认为这可能会导致人们选择退出这个进程。是的。你引用了《纽约时报》曾经刊登的一个故事，讲的是一个女人决定不参加最近的一场选举。她决定不投票。据我所知，她的朋友或兄弟姐妹对发生的事情有非常不同的感受。讲讲那个故事吧。所以，这个故事让我们觉得非常有趣，在我们开展
were working through our theoretic work. And it's this woman who talked about deciding that she wasn't going to turn out to vote. And she had these two close friends who basically started texting her repeatedly, almost trying to shame her into turning out and voting. And in the end, she didn't vote, so it was not effective. But it was effective in her essentially stopping being friends with these people, people who she reports actually having been friends with for a long time, I think. And the other thing that she reports that was especially kind of sad in some ways is that she actually never really engaged with politics again. It was such a poor experience for her that it led her to exit out of politics entirely. And you can see this story, I think, from both sides. I think the people who were trying to convince her to vote
理论研究的过程中，它一直留在我们的脑海里。故事讲的是这个女人决定不出来投票。她有两个要好的朋友基本上开始反复给她发短信，几乎是想用羞辱的方式逼她出来投票。最后，她还是没有投票，所以这种做法并没有奏效。但它确实有效地让她和这些人断绝了关系，据她所说，这些人其实是她认识很久的朋友。她提到的另一件事，在某种程度上尤其让人感到悲伤，那就是她实际上再也没有真正涉足过政治。这次糟糕的经历对她来说太痛苦了，导致她彻底远离了政治。我想，你可以从双方的角度来看待这个故事。我认为那些试图说服她投票的人
story, I think, from both sides. I think the people who were trying to convince her to vote genuinely wanted to see this person engage in politics. They genuinely leave politics important. They genuinely want people to vote. But what happened was an entirely opposing reaction, which sort of speaks to this idea of how we communicate the importance of politics to others. So there's something deeply ironic here because as you said, the deeply involved, you know, are deeply involved because they care so much. They have deep ideals very often about what's right and what's wrong and how to make things better, but paradoxically in terms of actual effectiveness, they might not actually be getting their way, not just because they're driving disengagement amongst some people, but also because, as you point out, the deeply engaged are also the ones who are least interested in compromise.
故事，我想，可以从双方的角度来看待。我认为那些试图说服她投票的人是真心希望看到这个人参与政治。他们真心认为政治很重要。他们真心希望人们投票。但结果却完全相反，这恰恰说明了我们如何向他人传达政治重要性的问题。所以这里面有一种深深的讽刺，因为正如你所说，那些深度投入的人之所以深度投入，你知道的，是因为他们太在乎了。他们往往对什么是对、什么是错以及如何把事情做好有着崇高的理想，但从实际效果来看，他们可能适得其反，这不仅是因为他们在某些人中间引发了疏离感，还因为正如你所指出的，高度投入的人往往也是最对妥协不感兴趣的人。
So compromise is a dirty word when it comes to the people who are the most deeply engaged in politics. What does it mean for a democracy, Yana, when the people who are in the fray, who stay in the fray, are stay in the fray, are the ones who say any compromise with the other side is effectively betrayal and treason, and we are driving out the people who might in some ways be more amenable to compromise. Oh, I think there are sort of two ways to look at this. I think one is more and more people who are less involved are driven out of politics. We see more and more people who are less involved are driven out of politics,
所以当谈到那些最深度参与政治的人时，“妥协”成了一个脏话。雅娜，对于一个民主党或整个民主制度来说，这意味着什么？当那些身处风口浪尖、并且留在那里的，正是那些声称与另一方进行任何妥协实际上都是背叛和叛国的人，而我们却在把那些在某种程度上更愿意妥协的人赶走。哦，我觉得可以从两种方式来看待这一点。一种是越来越多较少参与的人被排挤出政治，我们看到越来越多较少参与的人被排挤出政治，
we see more of these people who are deeply involved, basically engaging with each other, fully convinced of their own level of interest, basically just reinforcing each other's views. And then you have another half of your electorate who is becoming less and less and less engaged. What are we losing in this case? Are we losing certain voices that could essentially be represented? Are we changing who is being represented? Are we essentially altering the extent to which government can be responsible? I think these are all things that we should kind of think about when we think about what
我们看到越来越多这些高度投入的人基本上在互相接触，他们完全确信自己对政治的兴趣程度，基本上只是在不断强化彼此的观点。然后你的选民的另一半却变得越来越不参与。在这种情况下，我们失去了什么？我们是否失去了一些本该代表特定声音的发言权？我们是否改变了被代表的对象？我们是否在根本上改变了政府能够负起责任的程度？我认为当我们思考当
it means when we give the deeply involved so much voice. One of the most surprising things about your thesis as I was reading your work is how many Americans think of people who belong to their own political party who are deeply involved. Obviously, many Americans dislike partisans on the other side who are deeply involved, but how do people think about people on their own side who are deeply involved? Certainly, people like those on their own side who are deeply involved. Certainly, people like those on their own side who are deeply involved a lot better than they like those on the other side
我们赋予深度投入者如此多的发言权时，这些都是我们应该思考的问题。当我阅读你的著作时，你这个论点中最令人惊奇的事情之一，就是有多少美国人对他们自己政党中深度投入的人的看法。显然，许多美国人不喜欢对方党派中深度投入的党派人士，但人们是如何看待自己这一边深度投入的人的呢？当然，人们比讨厌另一边的人更能接受自己这一边
who are deeply involved. But there is also some sense that people aren't necessarily all that excited about people who are deeply involved on their own side as well. People who are not deeply involved don't exactly love people who tweet about politics even from their own side. So certainly, certainly, I think if we kind of truth-served people, they would say, well, if you're gunna tweet about politics, at least do it from my side.
深度投入的人。但人们也在某种程度上觉得，对于自己这一边那些深度投入的人，大家其实也没有那么兴奋。那些不深度投入的人并不怎么喜欢那些在推特上大谈政治的人，哪怕这些人来自他们自己的阵营。所以当然，当然，我认为如果我们对人们进行真实民调，他们会说，好吧，如果你非要在推特上谈论政治，至少站在我这边。
But they don't necessarily love that either. I sense in some ways that there is an irony in your work, Yana, because you've mentioned in a couple of different ways that you yourself might belong to the ranks of the people who are deeply involved. You talked about it briefly in the context of many of your friends on social media being deeply involved. You have a critique of the deeply involved and sort of the effect they're having on politics. At some level, are you also critiquing your own life and your own approach to politics? By my definition, I probably am quite deeply involved. And in fact, I do, in fact, check the news
但他们不一定真的很喜欢这种行为。雅娜，我在某种程度上觉得你的作品中有一种讽刺意味，因为你曾从几个不同的角度提到，你自己可能就属于深度投入者的行列。你在社交媒体上提到过，你的许多朋友都是深度投入者，这只是简短的背景。你对深度投入者以及他们对政治产生的影响持批判态度。在某种程度上，你是不是也在批判你自己的生活和对待政治的方式？按我的定义，我可能确实是高度投入的。事实上，我确实会在
in the morning when I wake up. In that sense, I do think that I am critiquing my own life in a way. I found at a number of points actually having to remind myself, this is Twitter. This is not the world. There are people out there who are much more concerned about where their next paycheck is going to come from, whether they have time to spend with their kids, then with the latest thing the president has tweeted. And I think working on this has been a helpful reminder of this constant voice that I should hear
早上醒来时查看新闻。从这个意义上说，我确实觉得我是在某种程度上批判自己的生活。我发现在好几个节点上，我其实不得不提醒自己：这是推特，这可不是真实世界。外面还有很多人，他们更关心的是下一张薪水支票从哪里来、是否有时间陪孩子，而不是总统发了什么最新的推特。我想从事这项研究对我是一个有益的提醒，提醒我脑海中应该一直回响着一个声音：
in my head of, this is Twitter. This is not real life. Yana Krupnikov is a political scientist at Stony Brook University. Her upcoming book, written with her fellow political scientist, John Barry Ryan, is called The Other Divide, Polarization and Disengagement in American Politics. Yana, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Midro-O-Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Correll, Autumn Barnes and Andrew
这是推特，这不是现实生活。雅娜·克鲁普尼科夫是石溪大学的政治学家。她即将出版的新书是与同为政治学家的约翰·巴里·瑞安共同撰写的，书名为《另一道分水岭：美国政治中的两极分化与脱离》。雅娜，感谢你今天来到《隐秘大脑》。谢谢你邀请我。《隐秘大脑》由隐秘大脑传媒公司制作。Midro-O-Media是我们独家广告销售合作伙伴。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·科雷尔、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁
Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Special thanks this week to our former producers, Parth Shah and Thomas Liu, who played a vital role in building this episode. Our unsung hero today is Kara McGurk-Allison. Long time listeners to this show may know her name
查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐秘大脑》的执行主编。本周我们要特别感谢前制片人帕思·沙和托马斯·刘，他们在打造这一期节目中发挥了至关重要的作用。我们今天的无名英雄是卡拉·麦格克-艾利森。这个节目的老听众可能知道她的名字
from the first year of Hidden Brain. She was one of our founding producers and carried much of the weight in getting the podcast up and running. More recently, she has provided me with essential advice and support as we launched our new production company. From suggesting a payroll provider to connecting us with several members of our current team, Kara has helped to shape hidden brain in significant ways. We are so grateful for her kind and generous spirit. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. Get more information about us at hiddenbrain.org.
来自《隐秘大脑》的第一年。她是我们的创始制片人之一，承担了让这个播客筹备并运营起来的大部分工作。最近，随着我们推出新的制作公司，她为我提供了宝贵的建议和支持。从推荐薪资服务商到帮我们联系现团队的多位成员，卡拉以重大方式塑造了《隐秘大脑》。我们对她善良慷慨的精神深表感激。想要了解更多《隐秘大脑》的内容，您可以在脸书和推特上关注我们。访问 hiddenbrain.org 获取更多关于我们的信息。
If you like this episode and like our show, please remember to tell your friends. If they don't know how to subscribe to our podcast, please show them. Thanks for listening, I'm Shankar Vedantam. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢这一集节目，也喜欢我们的节目，请记得告诉你的朋友。如果他们不知道如何订阅我们的播客，请教教他们。谢谢收听，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。